A Pâques, on entend plusieurs sons de cloches.
Mais pourquoi a-t-on du mal à reconnaître notre propre voix quand elle est produite par un enregistrement ?
Quand il sort d’un haut-parleur,
le son de notre voix se propage dans l’air.
Les molécules qui composent l’air sont mises
en mouvement par la vibration du haut-parleur.
Elles se compriment et se détendent.
La vibration se diffuse de proche en proche
jusqu’à nos tympans qui vibrent à leur tour
ce qui génère un signal qui est transmis au cerveau.
Quand nous parlons, le son que nous produisons
ne se déplace pas uniquement dans l’air.
Il se propage également dans nos tissus.
Les os de la boite crânienne en particulier.
Le signal qui arrive à notre cerveau
est donc légèrement différent.
Un peu plus grave que le son de cette
« capsule de déconfiné » qui arrive à vos oreilles.
Si vous avez aimé cette capsule
N'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
Sachez que vous pouvez également voir ou revoir
ces vidéos en cliquant sur le côté, en haut ou en bas.
Et pour être sûr de n’en louper aucune,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Allez à bientôt et n’oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.